your cloud application has a lot of data
moving over many parts of the public and
the private Internet but what if you
want a heavier head and defining exactly
what paths your data can take in this
episode of cloud networking we'll talk
about how to define traffic routing
between networks stay tuned one common
problem with networking is that you need
the ability to link networks together
without allowing the data to be visible
to every user in every location for
example let's say company a and B share
a common wall in a building and each
have their own private networks but then
wish to connect them together without
giving up their current network
configuration this would mean making
both networks use different IP address
ranges and set up a router that connects
to both of these networks to pass
traffic between them
traditionally sending up a router for an
on-premise network requires a fair bit
of heavy lifting you physically
assembled these things together to build
interconnectivity between users and the
applications that used implementing all
of this could take days or even weeks
and as a network grows the associated
management and cost to operate it also
grows disproportionately larger for your
company but with Google cloud platform
Software Defined routing means every VP
C Network uses a scalable distributed
virtual routing mechanism GCP routes
define the paths network traffic takes
from a VM instance to other destinations
these destinations can be inside your V
PC network for example and another VM or
outside of it even though some routes
can be applied selectively the routing
table for a V PC network is defined at
the global V PC network level let's take
a closer look every route consists of a
destination and a next hop which are IP
addresses or ranges of IP addresses
traffic whose destination IP is within
the destination range is sent to the
next hop for delivery each VM instance
has a controller that's kept informed of
all its routes from in the network's
routing table each packet leaving a VM
is sent to the next top of an applicable
route based on a routing order when you
add a delete a route the set of changes
is propagated to the VM controllers
using an eventually consistent design
this
means that you have simplicity and
centralized control a high degree of
automation built-in security and
encryption and high performance now
there are two types of routes on a GCP
VPC system generated routes or custom
routes system generated routes give you
a default route and subnet route the
default route defines a path for traffic
from your V PC to Google services and
the public Internet the subnet route
defines a path for your traffic into
your V PC to each subnet this is how V
PC peering works V PC peers always
exchange all subnet routes custom routes
me and you create static routing
yourself or dynamic routes using Google
Cloud router let's walk through static
route setup here I have two V pcs setup
in u.s. East and us central I also set
up a VPN gateway on both sides and
created two IPSec tunnels between them I
have an Ohio server in the US east V PC
and a warehouse server in the US central
V PC but I still can't pick the internal
IP of the warehouse server from the Ohio
server I need to create two static
routes to enable traffic to be forwarded
into the tunnel we have default routes
created for East Network but we're going
to create custom static routes first
let's create a route from east to
central click create route specify a
name for the route select an existing
network where the route will apply the
destination IP range is the central
subnet internal IP range I'll skip
priority for now but you would use this
to determine routing order if routes
have the same destinations select a
target instance tag or leave it blank to
apply the route to all instances in the
network select a next hop for the route
I'll select my VPN tunnel and click
create now I'll create another route for
traffic from central to east and voila
I can now ping the internal IP of the
warehouse server from the Ohio server
keep in mind that with static routes you
have to create or maintain a routing
table and a topology change on either
network requires you to manually update
static routes
also started grouts can't automatically
reroute traffic if a link fails but
static routing is perfect for small
networks with stable topologies there's
so much more I can say around routing
but it's clear that Google's virtual
routing is what connects all the moving
pieces between subnets and a V PC and
even to your local network on premise
stay tuned for more networking and end
and remember optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth
[Music]